hey everybody its Pete Holmes with the
Pete Home Show where Beatty has asked us
to cover the Hip Hop Awards I'm as
surprised as you are new experience here
one of the biggest names in the game
most ripping it across I love what
you're wearing oh man you know I keep it
flat at all times you know real simple
velour sweat suit few hundred caters you
else you are I gotta share a few hundred
K in yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no big
deal no not at all but slight work take
a box truck yeah no not we won't do that
well were you always to chains as far as
this personality I mean in your heart
city boy Timmy boy I like that that's
what they called me I used to swim with
my t-shirt on yeah a little bit right
before I came I near with you perfect
I would expect nothing less Oh sticky
icky icky baby I'm a medical marijuana
patient from the state of Michigan State
there you go na kama everything xiety
old trouble sleeping old tomfoolery
nervous and group handle ended after
newt green carpet events work felt great
just enjoy being high do people ever ask
you to rap for them
I'm not gonna ask you to do it ah that's
right because I'm a comedian people ask
me to do jokes for them why don't we
just take a quiet moment to let each
other be ourselves just feels right
doesn't it nothin this jagged
I love it for you kinda looks like the
background from The Fresh Prince of
bel-air the beginning for such Versace
new dick Fresh Prince pants have you
seen the movie huh no get your tea up
it'll get ya they don't sound like my
type of move no I think it's right up
your alley
oh we could take our shirts off and just
watch it together you got a home theater
we can't watch it you know I'm not a
very cool person but this is my job
let me ask you if you weren't an emcee
what do you think you'd be doing
probably owned a grocery store all right
old Snoopy yeah and be selling weed
through the back dough
there you go I go there I might be
producing a big Home Show dude I would
hire you as our band any day we got a
good rapport let me have that sweat suit
when you guys go out who's the wingman
we bubbly wing we actually we say that
we say we man wing wing man wagon are we
getting it wet a lot gotta say it's
nicer than fine height six six five six
five almost exactly do you need kind of
an opp version of you in your entourage
I definitely don't need you in my
drawers period you gotta get some taco
meat on there all right that little fuzz
ain't gonna work what is taco meat you
need some taco meat over what does that
mean I got some chalk will be under here
I can't show those chests here yeah I'm
Lithuanian we're a hairless people I got
things to offer no I do like to laugh a
lot so maybe you can you know help take
the stress away but for the most part
I'm cool I'm cool as hell
I still feel like when the cameras are
off it's gonna be enough yeah what do
you think my hip-hop name would be MC no
taco meat cracker boy iceberg Charlie
boy little Conan or whitey did
all whitey then well that was a very new
experience
I want to thank dat I've been for the
Pete Home Show all whitey then all
whiting pen